what's going on everybody welcome to
another open CV with python tutorial in
this tutorial we're going to be talking
about gradients as well as edge
detection so let's go ahead and get
started we are already have basically
some stuff going on in in here that we
really don't actually need anymore so
I'm going to go ahead and remove all of
this basically here so if you're just
now following along go ahead and you can
go to you can either copy and paste this
code it's really not that much code and
all honesty or you can and in fact we
don't need the HSB or you can go to
Python program net-net go to this
tutorial and just copy paste to start
off now so we've got the nothingness
that we don't care about in our frame
and now we're going to let's go ahead
and first we'll just do a laplacian so
lap raishin equals cv - should have kept
some of that image show anyway lap
Latian it's hard to spell
we're going to apply that to the frame
and you see v2 dot cv underscore 64 f
that is just data type you might not
even have to specify that I want to be
surprised that's default and let's go
ahead and see v2 dot M show and then
we'll call this beef
I don't know original and then comma
frame and then we'll go see BTN show and
then we'll do laplacian and laplacian
cool that should be good we'll run that
and there we have our lab elation
gradient that is applied here now
basically this is a great that would go
kind of both ways now a lot of times
you've got an x gradient or a like a y
gradient basically so we can go ahead
and add those as well so let me go
let's looks like a really bad TV maybe
you guys don't remember
you know anybody remember when you had
like a satellite and it would like the
snowy channels but you could just like
barely make out some people sometimes if
your signal was like okay ish anyway uh
so we've got lap elation and then we're
going to do Sobel X record Monday we had
snowy TVs anyway cv2 Sobel and then
we're going to apply that Sobel ah to
the frame and then we're going to say CV
to dot basically this exact same data
type and then one zero and then k size
will be five that's your kernel size and
let's just copy this okay so this is
basically X Y so then we flip these
around zero 1 so Y and this will give
you basically your directional sort of
intensity with gradients so take this
paste paste so Bowl X X X X Y and Y so
save and run those and there you have
your gradients okay so one is a vertical
and one is more horizontal gradient as
you can probably see other than one is
just in general so with lab elation
actually it really all these gradients
especially if you converted to grayscale
first and then applied these gradients
you you can kind of start to drive some
information so these gradients can be
used for directional intensity in some
cases but they're I kind of think
there's better options out there but you
can use them and especially like this
laplacian one you can see edges really
well and so you can start to define edge
detectors based on these but you don't
need to because there are already edge
detectors edge detectors built in so
let's close that out open or close that
and go back to our script and what we're
interested in now is an edge detector
now there
multiple edge detectors out there we're
going to use the canny edge detector so
we're going to come down here and saying
the edges equals C v2 dot canny we apply
it to the frame and we'll use a 100 by
200 here and then we will show edges
edges and here is basically just
modified one of them but this this gives
you like a bunch of edges based on a
certain region basically so like what if
we what do we change this to let's do
like 50 and 50 okay so you can see based
on a much smaller size here we've got a
lot of noise happening so we don't want
that much noise so let's try maybe maybe
let's try a hundred by a hundred but
maybe you want that much noise you know
like for example if I hold up my arm you
can see a lot of my hair shows up on the
edge detector and a lot of my head hair
does and my facial hair shows up but if
you want less edges and like the more
important kind of edges you can do 200
by 200 or even 100 by 200 let me show
that okay so but we're still losing some
that screen up top or the picture up
there it's actually I guess we're kind
of look this is like the reflection of
my light I suppose interesting anyway
another thing to note with edge
detection as you can see that there's a
dog bed in the background and it's got
kind of like a shadow coming off of it
and it's it acts like that's an edge not
only is it an edge but because that
shadow continues it's almost like it's
overlapping the dog bed that's actually
I mean the shadow is overlapping it but
it's obviously nothing is actually
overlapping that dog bed so it's kind of
interesting surprise I can't get like a
decently it's either a lot of noise or
we lose some stuff
whatever anyway probably 100 by 200 is
the best one anyway I think it's pretty
cool like the little edge detection for
detecting edges on stuff is actually I
think that's pretty cool anyway that's
it for image gradients in all that in
the next tutorial we're going to be
talking about template matching
basically if you have an image of
something you can match it as long as
you have a relatively almost identical
match it's actually really quick really
easy in the code to match it in amongst
a much larger image so that's we're
going to be talking about the next
tutorial if you have questions comments
concerns whatever about this tutorial
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support subscriptions and until next
time